it's got to be true right the scale that
we use to measure things can't be the
right one there's got to be something
bigger an infinite scale that we will
never be aware of could our entire
universe just be an atom of another
universe much bigger than else could all
we know and love just be part of the
shell of an ant blissfully unaware of
water is responsible for one bad move on
his behalf
one fall could mean the end of our
universe as well as many others
likewise as I scratch my skin am i
destroying millions of worlds I could be
and you could be too I've often thought
if this is how easy it is for a universe
to be destroyed why are we still around
it could probably come down to
probabilities sure millions of things
are destroyed each second but many more
aren't and so we've probably got a very
small probability of being spontaneously
destroyed but if the theory is true then
it will eventually be us we will
eventually be that itch that someone
destroys another reason why we may have
survived so long is that we might be on
a very different timescale to the other
universe because we would be so small in
comparison and because time is relative
huge speed for us could be a tiny speed
for the other universe and
a second for them could be hundreds of
years for us so does this mean that
doomsday could have already started
could someone's shoe already be closing
down on the ant which we are a part of
but at our passing of time means that
it'll still be hundreds of years before
we feel the effects or as our doomsday
closer than we thought